[music]
>> I welcome all of you once again back
to the training program. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullah wabarakatuh. Wa
alaykumu s-salam warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be on all of you.
And today in this extended session,
which I did not know would come on the
second day, but alhamdulillah we are
lucky that it is on the second day
because the next day
is a rest day,
not completely rest day.
And inshallah we'll try and finish the
session
in about 2 hours.
The first is
the techniques
of giving references.
And particularly today we are going to
discuss references
from the glorious Quran. Point number
one, what is the requirement
of giving reference?
What is the advantage
For example,
if I say,
"The Quran says that dawah is fardh
for every Muslim."
And I say,
"Quran says in Surah Al Imran, chapter
number three, verse number 110,
that dawah is fardh for every Muslim."
Which is more effective?
Why? Because
evidence,
proof,
stronger impression.
Yes, brother.
It's a specific message.
Specific message.
Some said authenticity, some said yes,
brother. Because Quran carries more
weight.
Quran carries more weight.
Yes, Quran carries more weight is
correct, but the answer is not correct.
Quran carries more weight is correct.
But I said both use the word Quran.
Both the times I said Quran, no?
Yes or no?
But one is with reference, one is
without reference. Yes, brother. With a
reference is
giving confidence. Confidence.
Yes, brother Vinod.
So that when people listen, they can
check back whether whether check back.
Yes, brother Arshad.
That leaves room for no doubt and
confusion.
And shows that you're truthful.
It leaves for no doubt and confusion and
confirms the truth.
Alhamdulillah.
All the answers are correct in one way
or the other except that Quran gives
more weight. Yes, Quran gives more
weight, but both the way Quran gives.
Yes, brother Ibrahim.
It's I'm directly passing on a message.
You're directly passing It's direct from
a message from its source. It's not
direct from opinion is
>> are direct sources. The first source I
said Quran says that it is fardh for
every Muslim to do dawah. And the
second, but first is without reference
and the second is with reference. Both
say Quran.
Both the sources are Quran.
It turns from a blanket statement into a
strong statement.
Blanket statement to a strong statement.
Not a blanket statement.
A less specific statement, a general
statement to a specific statement. It's
not blanket statement. A general
statement to a specific statement. Quran
says is general, both are correct, but
specifically verse number so-and-so.
Yes, brother.
Because Islam is basically on proof.
Islam is based on proof.
Yes.
Any other answers? Yes.
Brother Sugimoto.
Yes, Sugimoto to for the listener to
check, double check.
>> No, that for listener to check, double
check.
Anyone else wants to add?
Brother Arshad wants to give a second
edition. Yes, brother.
It shows that you are an authority on
the subject. It shows that you are an
authority on the subject. Yes, that's an
additional point.
Yes, brother Ibrahim.
Similar.
Similar, they can't ask what they're
going to ask potentially next cuz likely
you make a statement, the next question
is going to say, "Where's your proof?"
But you're jumping ahead of that
statement. Where is the proof? So giving
the proof in advance, correct.
There are various reasons why giving
reference is beneficial.
And most of the reasons have been
discussed. Number one
is for authenticity.
Many a time you say Quran says this.
Now, how will you check whether he is
right or wrong? Authenticity.
Number one. Second, it gives specific
that this is it where it says.
Third, it gives confidence.
Authenticity.
It gives specific ideas, confidence, and
for people
who doubt, they can verify.
People may say, "Where did they say?"
And there are people when they give
talks,
many a time it's not there. You know,
some people quote Bukhari says this.
Now, where are you going to search in
nine volumes? And after you search, it's
not there only.
So giving reference
gives authenticity,
makes it specific,
gives confidence, and
many a time
some people
want to prove you wrong.
You know, there have been times when
many skeptics of Islam when they hear my
talk, they said, "This person quoting
Quran,
one, two verses, 10 verses have to be
wrong. And I'll prove it to him he is
wrong." And they check.
And then they get shocked.
20 verses references given,
all 20 correct.
And that may be the part
for them to come closer to Islam.
Many accepted Islam only because of
this.
Number one,
besides giving authenticity, even you
yourself are reconfirming, yes, it is
part of the Quran.
You yourself are being sure, yes, it is
there. It gives you confidence.
Yes, I heard some speaker saying it's
there in the Quran. So you keep it there
in the Quran. And if someone asks you a
question, it's there, I'll have to check
up.
Not that you have to know every
reference of what you say,
but if you know most of the references
of what you say, your lecture is on a
different level altogether.
Giving reference in the lecture
is one thing.
Giving reference in a question-answer
session is another thing.
Giving reference in a lecture is easy.
One has to know the technique.
Giving reference in a question-answer
session is multiple times
or lecture method he says. In
question-answer you also answer with
reference.
It puts you on a different level of
dawah. Then you quote reference, not
from the Quran, from the Bible. Quran,
understand Bible,
Veda,
Gita.
Inshallah, all of you will be doing the
same.
And masha Allah, you all are done
educated big. We have our children in
our school
from the age of four we train.
You see all of them giving references.
But it's dangerous, huh? They argue with
us with reference. So sometime arguing
with our children becomes difficult. And
the teachers have a tough time.
You know, these students of ours
to correct us, they quote the Quran. And
sometimes they win.
Not misquote, they quote it for the
benefit.
The teachers sometime worry that so I
told them,
"Now even you do the course."
So if you do the course, you can reply.
If you don't do the course, you are on
the receiving end. And but naturally no
teacher can say if Quran says I will not
do.
So that is the reason when I have a
discussion with my wife, I have a tough
time. She said, "I am a dai, I am a
dai." She quotes the Quran. I have to
quote another verse of the Quran to
counter which I give you an example.
I gave an example yesterday. She says,
"Why don't you sleep? Quran says Allah
has made night to sleep." Then I have to
quote another verse. Allah says,
"Blessed are those people who sacrifice
their bed and they are the ones who
shall receive." She said, "Okay." Even
quoting Quran for zakat is
not going to work. Not going to work.
That is the only thing that works. But
the different thing is that even she
knows the technique, I know the
technique. So it's a jugalbandi.
Jugalbandi means it's a debate between
two people.
And alhamdulillah, when we are at the
same level,
it's good. Therefore, discussing with
people of knowledge is a different
ballgame altogether.
There are things, I mean, when I play
with my children, there is a game that
people say, "Okay, let's play
Antakshari." Do you know Antakshari?
Have you heard the word Antakshari?
Those from India will know Antakshari.
Antakshari means you have to sing film
songs.
You say a song,
the alphabet the song ends with with
that word you have to start a new song.
It's not Islamic.
I don't believe in it, but you have to
convert what is un-Islamic to Islamic.
Many times you have to reply with songs.
All these songs are almost all of it
haram. I don't want to repeat it, but
you reply with another song. So, we say,
"Okay, let's have a debate on verses of
the Quran."
Debate or a discussion. You quote a
verse of the Quran, the reply should be
another verse of the Quran. So, for that
you have to have knowledge.
And with reference.
>> [music]
[music]